the raid in rala the largest that we've
seen in a very long time started around
1:00 a.m. in the morning uh what the
Israeli Army did is they came down uh a
street just over there they started
using tear gas and sound grenades uh to
then clear the street then they took
over the street here with at least 20
armored vehicles including armored
personnel carriers now I was witnessing
all of this from my hotel balcony just
up there and what they did next was they
went into this money exchange place let
me just take you inside what they did
was they cut this door
here and then they went
inside and they actually raided a safe
inside here just below uh there but you
can see the massive amount of damage
that's included all this glass is from
the glass Frontage of this shop so what
the Israelis are saying is that they'
designated five five different locations
three here in rala and one in taram one
in Janine as being terrorist financing
organizations the U of Galant the
defense minister actually signed uh that
deal and that's when all of these
coordinated raids happened now once
they' raided this they actually went
into rala and raided three uh two more
shops uh there was very intense clashes
going on one Palestinian died and at
least 15 others were injured now the
clashes took place over a period of
about 5 hours eventually when the uh
Israeli Army did withdraw they still
came under clashes even as they were
leaving Imran Khan Al jazer ramala